now you auditioned for Sandler's movie
right I did no 100 how many times
with Adam the second time
never without him never without him was
Adam in the room
uh nope he wasn't even in the room no I
met Adam are you his love interest yeah
it was a really weird situation because
originally Salma Hayek was cast and then
she got pregnant so she had to fall out
and I um at the time randomly had a
general with Heather Perry
I know Heather Perry you don't show me
yeah Sony she's not there anymore is she
I don't know sure but she she ran
Sandler's company Happy Madison yes yeah
yeah so I had a you know I had a great
meeting with her and in the meeting she
was like
[Music]
it's me and we're like in the golf cart
and she's like introduces me to Adam
Sandler he's playing basketball are you
doing good to see you all right
that's exactly what he sounds like you
look like Lopez
that's so good and then I met Dennis
Dugan the director yeah and then Dennis
like oh this is all happening and Dennis
is like
yeah great uh I I yeah you're perfect I
would love for you to read and I and
then he's like so when can you audition
please I think was so weird what would
you say I was like
things are so hilarious I was like well
I'm doing a movie in Vancouver like I'm
actually flying to go finish a movie in
Vancouver so like when I rap maybe in
like 10 days I can come back and
audition and he was like okay
great
so I auditioned and I have to work on
this accent it's not like you know like
I wasn't gonna half-ass this what accent
was it Palestinian
that's not easy I know
so then I audition it went really well
apparently I guess the tapes were seen
but I know that there was a little
um behind the scenes like I'd heard
later on that before they actually
offered the part to me Adam had sort of
called around
to be like
tell me about shriki like we're thinking
about her for this
is this a good thing is this about
really so they want to know if you were
easy to work with easy to work with
would I be able to hold my own opposite
him like she know her lines big deal
right because Sandler is Sandler and all
his the all his co-stars have always
been you know
you know amazing what's he like on set
was he like uh do it do it again but
like say the line like this and then
turn your head like always throwing [ __ ]
at you he was well definitely you know
him and Dugan directed even though
Dennis Dugan was the director Adam
obviously was very involved
um but he was just so fun he created
such a relaxed atmosphere
and
it it just felt like super organic so
even if there was like something that we
were working out it just felt
it was like fun it never felt like there
was this enormous pressure
it was playful yeah he's a wonderful guy
he's a really wonderful I love that guy
he's so kind to me
I mean working with Sandler it had to be
like just like you're sitting there in
there say action you're like looking at
Adam Sandler it says like legendary
comedian Legend guy we all grew up
watching legendary and you're now you're
working with him it's got to be kind of
like Shell Shocked like oh my you had to
get that out of your system how do you
get it out of your system I am an actor
I'm acting now learn your [ __ ] and
forget about Adam Sandler well I mean I
think that
I don't know that you honestly do
because every day of that movie I just
remember being like
and then and then imagine
that I'm on the set
and there's a night where it's
Adam Sandler
John Turturro Kevin Nealon
Rob Schneider and myself
doing a scene and I was like okay for
real what the [ __ ] is going on right now
did you say that like to anybody who
would listen like I was like this is so
surreal and like John Turturro oh this
is amazing I mean he's so amazing and
again like
one of the nicest humans I remember he
was he was he would get such a kick out
of it because I don't know if you know
this but he was very good friends with
Madonna Like That was yeah back in the
day in New York and somehow or other we
got talking and I was telling him of
like my obsession with Madonna when I
was a kid so literally we would be
sitting I'd be like okay so tell me some
more stories really some more like you
tell you some provocative stories just
like fun stuff not you know but it was
really cute and he got such like a kick
out of it like he loved how much I loved
her